[Music]
so if you're trying to communicate a
complex topic such as mathematics or a
mathematical problem to the general
public who might not be familiar with
the specifics behind that problem there
are many different ways to help you get
that concept across and one of the ways
that we do this in mathematicals is to
use videos and things that are visually
appealing to people so by using lots of
visual aids so bright colors and
cartoons and word prompts on your screen
you can engage and capture the audience
in different ways that you might not be
able to do if you're just speaking in
terms of equations and mathematics when
we're more creative about how we present
and how we talk about math it makes it
more relatable to people from a variety
of backgrounds and cultures and
experiences
when we are creative in how we explain
or how we relate
mathematical concepts we can use things
from sports entertainment or real world
to help really ground the principles
that we're learning and the theories
that we're learning to something
relatable so the more creative we can be
in explaining how math is related to the
world around us how it's related to
things that we are invested in the more
likely it is to resonate with the people
around us as soon as a problem is posed
our instinct is to find the solution but
remember often there's more than one
solution and usually there's more than
one path to it